[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans parlement hebdo
l'émission qui revient sur les temps
forts à l'assemblée et au sénat et pour
commenter toute l'actualité de la
semaine notre invité est aujourd'hui
cela pinel bonjour vous êtes ancien
ministre député liberté territoire de
tarn et garonne merci d'être avec nous
bienvenue sur ce plateau silvia pinal
vous êtes né à l'union près de toulouse
on va avoir votre carte d'identité
express vous êtes députée de
tarn-et-garonne
élu depuis 2007 vous êtes alors la
benjamine de l'assemblée
vous avez été ministre sous le
quinquennat françois hollande vous avez
notamment donner votre nom un dispositif
du code des impôts au dispositif pinel
pour favoriser l'implantation de
commerces en 2017 vous êtes candidate à
la primaire citoyenne de gauche issu du
parti radical vous siégez aujourd'hui
dans le groupe liberté et territoires
alors sylvia pinel
aujourd'hui vous vous définissez comme
ans comme une députée d'opposition ou
comme un soutien la majorité une députée
libre uni députée indépendante
c'est-à-dire que je peux parfois
partager un certain d'orientation du
gouvernement et parfois au contraire m'y
opposer fortement mais je note que
depuis plusieurs mois
c'est plutôt je vote plutôt contre parce
que je considère que les orientations
qui sont prises ne répondent pas aux
préoccupations de nos de nos concitoyens
et aggravent un certain nombre de
fractures d'inégalités alors par contre
sur votre présentation c'est le
dispositif d'investissement locatif et
c'est sur le logement mais c'est pas sûr
les commerces bastia sur une loi je
remercie aussi un volant gt mise
l'artisanat c'était une loi pour
accompagner les tpe et ça soutient le
logement social c'est ce que vous
invoquez c'était sur le logement
et bien c'est bien final on va justement
entendre votre parole libre sur
l'actualité de la semaine discussions
tendues à l'assemblée sur la réduction
de l'aide médicale d'état pour les
étrangers en situation irrégulière
et une adoption houleuse au sénat d'un
texte pourtant consensuel qui vise à
lutter contre les violences conjugales
troisième point l'atterrissage du budget
de la sécu au sénat un projet de loi
unanimement rejetée par la gauche et la
droite et on commence avec la question à
la une la séance promettait d'être
animée au lendemain des annonces
d'edouard philippe sur l'immigration la
question de l'aide médicale d'état a
divisé les députés
[Musique]
la msp et cette aide médicale d'état qui
permet aux étrangers en situation
irrégulière de bénéficier de certains
soins de santé le gouvernement a décidé
une réduction de cette aide de quoi
soulever la polémique sur les bancs de
l'opposition fanny die au coeur de la
polémique
l'aide médicale d'état qui permet aux
étrangers en situation irrégulière de se
faire soigner le gouvernement à déposer
une série d'amendements
objectif affiché mieux contrôler l'accès
à l'oeil le et lutter contre les abus
avec à la clé une baisse de 15 millions
du budget de l'aide médicale d'état
sur un budget de plus de 900 millions
dans l'hémicycle la ministre de la santé
agnès buzyn défend la ligne du
gouvernement
je sais que la dépense da et me alimente
parfois une défiance sur le système
voire des fantasmes qu'il est difficile
de déconstruire pour rétablir la
confiance nos efforts doivent être
tournés vers l'amélioration de
l'efficience des dispositifs de prise en
charge des soins des personnes migrantes
de part et d'autre de l'hémicycle
l'opposition se livrent à un véritable
tir croisé contre le gouvernement d'un
côté la gauche accuse le gouvernement de
chasser sur les terres de la droite de
l'extrême droite
vous voulez séduire un électorat qui
vote extrême droite et pour cela vous
vous renier
au final vous à les renier vos valeurs
et vous allez renforcer le front
national c'est c'est pitoyable
de l'autre côté la droite dénonce une
mesure insuffisante
les républicains souhaitent supprimer la
et me pour la recentrer sur les soins
vitaux est urgent en lever 15 millions à
1 milliard en disant que c'est de la
fraude
franchement on est dans de la
communication c'est un début mais ce
n'est absolument pas ni crédible ni
suffisant tandis que sur les bancs du
rassemblement national marine le pen
plaide pour la suppression pure et
simple de l'aide médicale d'état ce
cinéma je commence à en avoir
le bol et je pense que les français ont
eux aussi ras le bol la seule mesure qui
soit véritablement efficace et de
supprimer totalement l'aide médicale
d'état
le sujet divise et jusque dans les rangs
de la majorité soixante-neuf députés de
la république en marche ont voté la
baisse du budget de la et mes maîtresses
ont voté contre et trois se sont
abstenus
silvia pinal on a réduit finalement là
et me mais le gouvernement n'a pas trop
toucher à la haie mais finalement est-ce
que ça vous choque quand même que le
gouvernement s'attaque à l'aide médicale
d'état
d'abord il ya plusieurs choses qui me
choquent on apprend à la veille un
certain nombre de mesures
le gouvernement le traduit dans la nuit
par voie d'amendement il n'y a ni débat
dans la commune dans les commissions
permanentes de l'assemblée consacré à
ces politiques là haut qui ne respectent
pas la démocratie ond de nanterre ne
respectent pas la donne
on n'a pas le temps d'étudier les
amendements en ce sens se précipitent
pour faire de la communication pour se
rapprocher de plus en plus de certains
partis d'extrême droite de la garonne
droite de la droite
et finalement on ne s'attaque pas aux
vrais sujets et c'est de la politique
pour vous ils chassent sur les thèses et
ces deux-là droit c'est une technique
politique qui finalement perdure depuis
quelques temps
regardez le débat sur les élections
européennes où le prince le parti
présidentiel a voulu s'enfermer dans un
face à face avec le front national
aujourd'hui on continue moi je trouve ça
très dangereux pour la démocratie en
général pour la démocratie parlementaire
en particulier
et puis ensuite il ya la question de
fond moi je suis très opposé à ce qu'on
légifère en catimini sur ces dispositifs
qui sont extrêmement utiles et qui font
la richesse et la fierté l'honneur de la
france que poser des problèmes aussi en
termes de santé publique notamment le
délai de trois mois de carence avant
d'accéder à la sécurité sociale de base
pour les demandeurs d'asile
finalement c'est ça qui a le plus depuis
ce qui m'a beaucoup choqué dans le débat
hier matin c'est l'amalgamme voulu
sûrement que l'on fait entre
l'immigration les étrangers en situation
irrégulière et les demandeurs d'asile on
a tout mélangé et ça c'est extrêmement
grave s'est voulu de la part du
gouvernement alors que le droit d'asile
est profondément sacré dans notre dans
notre pays et nous sommes nombreux à y
être très attachés parce que c'est ce
qui est justement au fondement de
certaines de nos convictions et de nos
valeurs et donc moi je trouve qu'on est
c'est très très dangereux que la
majorité le gouvernement se prête à ce
petit jeu d' amalgame
alors alors qu'on l'a toujours posée de
manière très claire se débat divise et
jusque dans les rangs de la majorité on
a entendu des paroles très fort des
diatribes notamment jennifer de tema
nous allons député lrm nous allons
achever l'humanisme le gouvernement
manque d'humanisme
quand on réduit la protection la
sécurité sociale l'accès aux soins pour
les demandeurs d'asile
effectivement on manque d'humanisme
parce que c'est un principe encore une
fois fondamental dans notre république
et puis lorsqu'on réduit l'accès aux
soins pour les étrangers en situation
irrégulière au prétexte d'un tourisme
médical
mais franchement on ne prend pas les
choses dans le bon ordre les loin à l
emmanuel macron de 2017 qui admirait
angela merkel et sa politique
d'ouverture aux migrants je trouve qu'il
ya vraiment du un grand décalage entre
ce qu emmanuel macron disait à ce moment
là et ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui sur la
question des quotas on a exactement le
même revirement et j'en suis très
injustement on va parler de la question
des quotas un autre sujet qui fait débat
dans la majorité
mercredi matin la garde des sceaux
nicole belloubet semblait critique sur
les quotas d'immigration professionnelle
quelques heures plus tard au sénat elle
est rentrée dans le rang
écoutez ce que j'ai dit ce matin
correspond exactement à ce qu'a présenté
le premier ministre c'est à dire que la
question des quotas n'est pas la seule
réponse à ces problèmes d'immigration il
y à d'autres éléments de réponse qui
figure dans le plan danse
vous avez des hommes avaient des
réserves sur la question des quotas dans
cette interview vous pouvez le dire
c'est être aussi intéressant d'avoir un
débat je pense que vous sûr interpréter
des propos je pense qu'il y à un
commentaire du commentaire qui n'a pas
lieu d'être ici je leur dis ici très
clairement je n'ai pas d'états d'âme et
le tout est un plan très cohérent vous
croyez la garde des sceaux pour vous at
elle fait l'objet d'un rappel à l'ordre
même d'ailleurs depuis la chine où
emmanuel macron s'est exprimé sur les
états d'âme de certains de ses ministres
je connais bien la garde des sceaux
puisqu'elle a été comme moi et lui dans
la même région mais ont même siégé
ensemble à la région midi-pyrénées à
l'époque donc je pense qu'effectivement
la garde des sceaux est mal à l'aise
comme peut-être d'ailleurs la ministre
de la santé sur la mva messieurs de la
gauche parce que effectivement je pense
que c'est une femme qui a des
convictions et des valeurs et je pense
qu'elle peut être effectivement mal à
l'aise parce que de quoi parlons nous on
parle d'immigration économique c'est à
peu près trente mille personnes par an
sur 268 me c'est quand même très peu et
de là à mettre en oeuvre des mesures
inefficaces incontrôlable et pas
pilotable jeu reprend là les mots du
président de la république pendant alors
à l'alors candidat alors que madame est
ce que je pense qu'il avait région à ce
moment là donc pour vous les quotas ne
sont pas une bonne idée et les quotas
sont ils de droite ou d'extrême droite
d'ailleurs c'est par mois deux qualifiés
- je pense que la question de revoir par
exemple la liste des métiers en tension
plus régulièrement pour que ça
corresponde justement une réalité c'est
pas nous c'est pas une mauvaise idée
pour être plus réactifs par contre sur
la question des quotas comment on va
faire dans quel territoire puis ça va
poser une question très concrète
le marché évolue les entreprises ont
parfois des besoins de réactivité que
son mari j'ai ça sera c'est ce que
disait le président la république a loué
un candidat en disant que c'est pas
c'est pas efficace parce que ça ne tient
pas compte de la réalité bien je pense
qu'ils devraient relire sans ces propos
de l'époque à ce qu emmanuel macron est
l'héritier de nicolas sarkozy et de
l'immigration choisie bien sûr les
quotas c'était quelque chose qui est
très marqué 1 par nicolas sarkozy
effectivement ce tout ce débat sur
l'immigration d'ailleurs il en a fait un
élément du débat national
or que c'était pas vraiment le sujet qui
revenait sur les ronds-points et dans
les débats a porté par les gilet jaune à
l'époque et donc on sent bien depuis ce
que je disais au début on sent bien une
volonté de poursuivre de de courir après
la droite et l'extrême droite et moi
c'est évidemment un point avec sur
lequel je ne peux pas être d'accord
alors que j'avais la conviction en 2017
et même un peu après que emmanuel macron
justement vous êtes bien géré et serait
un rempart par rapport à ces dérives que
j'ai toujours combattu et que j'ai
toujours tant d'années vous êtes déçu
j'ai changé de ligne de ce point de vue
là sur ce thématique là oui je suis
profondément déçu et peut-être même plus
encore que sur la politique économique
et sociale sur laquelle il y aurait déjà
beaucoup à dire mais là sur les valeurs
fondamentales
effectivement c'est décevant on va
passer sylvia pinel au deuxième thème de
cette émission
l'adoption dans la douleur de la
proposition de loi sur les violences
conjugales au sénat
[Musique]
c'est un sujet qui aurait dû être
consensuel de le texte a été adopté à
l'unanimité à l'assemblée au sénat
au contraire la gauche a claqué la porte
des débats dans une ambiance houleuse
explications cécile 6e a priori tout
devrait bien se passer
la proposition de loi sur les violences
conjugales se présentait comme un texte
consensuel les après plusieurs heures de
débats tout a basculé
les sénateurs de la gauche ont quitté
l'hémicycle toutes leurs propositions
étaient systématiquement rejeté cet
article 2 nous nous abstiendrons nous ne
feront pas obstacle mais ensuite nous
allons vous laisser travailler entre
chaque fois que des propositions
semblaient pouvoir emporter la
conviction de ceux qui étaient présents
gauche droite confondues le la droite
enfin la commission a demandé un scrutin
public il faut savoir qu'au sénat de
scrutin public c'est quelque chose
d'assez particulier puisque une seule
personne vote pour tout son groupe
en d'autres termes la droite peu
présente sur les bancs à grâce au
scrutin public pu imposer ces votes au
détriment de la gauche dont les rangs et
est étoffé être présent n'a aucun sens
aucun intérêt c'est en fin de compte les
absents qui votent avec le scrutin
public à président de groupe fait tomber
toutes les voix de son groupe
donc on les absents inflige une défaite
à ceux qui sont présents et quelque
chose de profondément immoral qui est
pas acceptable
et c'est pour ça qu'on a considéré à ce
moment là que on ne voulait plus
participer à ce jeu de dupes qu'était un
examen en trompe l'oeil d'une
proposition de loi marie mercier
la rapporteur du texte au sénat se
défend si la droite a utilisé le scrutin
public c'était pour assurer que les
amendements de la commission soit votée
nous avons suivi la position de notre
commission qui a été adoptée à
l'unanimité sur certains points nous
savions qu'il y aurait des débats en
séance c'est normal la séance est fait
pour ça nous on des scrutins publics
c'est parce que nous tenons à faire
passer ce qui a été voté en commission
plusieurs sénateurs ont également
regretté les blocages du gouvernement il
accuse à quelques semaines de la fin du
grenelle des violences conjugales de
vouloir garder le monopole sur le sujet
nous devons pouvoir travailler
et en tout en toute objectivité
en dehors du calendrier du gouvernement
les femmes ont trop attendu
il ya une urgence vitale pour ces femmes
et nous n'avons pas été hélas au rendez
vous hier soir le gouvernement rendra
ses conclusions sur le grenelle des
violences conjugales le 25 novembre
sylvia pinel est-ce que c'est dommage
que sur un sujet pareil les féminicides
alors que l'assemblée était parvenu à
être unanimes et on assiste à de telles
divisions au sénat c'est vraiment
regrettable que les débats ne se soit
pas déroulée de la même manière au sénat
que ce que nous avons connu ici à
l'assemblée nationale parce que c'est un
sujet important sur lequel la
mobilisation de l'ensemble de la classe
politique doit être au rendez vous était
le gars la santé quelqu'un à la
chandelle
les sujets sont graves 130 féminicide
cette année 1 quasiment on est à 1
féminicide tous les deux jours donc
c'est un sujet extrêmement grave qui
effectivement il ya l'effet m'initier
depuis il ya toutes les femmes victimes
de violences
plus les enfants qui assistent à ce
genre de scènes parfois donc c'est un
sujet qui doit nous rassembler très
largement et c'est ce qui s'est passé
ici à l'assemblée c'est bien je regrette
l'attitude au sénat parce que c'est
finalement à faiblir cette grande cause
qui est aujourd'hui nécessaire d'avancer
de trouver des mesures efficaces pour
protéger ces femmes c'est dommage que le
que la droite sénatoriale visiblement se
soit comportée ainsi elle a essayé de
justifier la sénatrice elle s était
convaincant ces arguments elle explique
pourquoi ça s'est passé comme ça vous
avez compris ce qui s'est passé pour
vous c'est de l'art je sais que le
système manawatu au sénat n'est pas le
même qu'à l'assemblée
je mange rien et vous allemand de
systèmes de vote l'heure exacte il y un
scrutin public sur scrutin public et
puis surtout on n'est pas assez nombreux
dans les mythes surtout c'est parce que
là c'était pour être majoritaire c'est
ça s'est félicité le sénateur et l'air
n'était pas là et donc ils ont utilisé
les scrutins publics pour faire adopter
un certain nombre de mesures
moi je regrette que sur un sujet pareil
on n'entende pas aussi les oppositions
du sénat 1 comme il y avait travaillé on
sait que le rance
signol marais perdre honnêtement on
connaît on peut laisser deux sénatrices
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec l'une
laurence recense étiez ministre voilà
donc je connais leurs engagements sur le
sujet mais j'ai vu aussi dans les images
que vous nous avez présenté des
sénatrice radicale qui ont aussi
beaucoup d'engagement sur ce sur ce
sujet c'est encore une fois c'est un
sujet qui rassemble toutes les
formations politiques parce que le sujet
était essentielle
le sujet alors le sait la proposition de
loi instaure un certain nombre de
mesures parmi elles un bracelet anti
rapprochement pour le conjoint violent
s'il accepte est ce que pour vous c'est
une bonne mesure
est ce que c'est suffisant alors moi je
considère effectivement que c'est une
bonne mesure et ça fait longtemps que je
pense que d'autres pays qui l'ont mis à
l'espagne par exemple qu'il avait mis en
place à bien avant nous ont eu des
résultats probants
mais comme sur ce sujet est complexe et
on peut pas dire que le bracelet sera la
réponse unique
la seule qui permettra de résoudre ce
fléau
je crois qu'il nous faut un arsenal
juridique multiples avec plusieurs
outils plusieurs procédures qui nous
permette réellement de le combattre et
d'être efficace et notamment dans la
libération aussi de la parole des femmes
parce qu on a encore trop de femmes qui
se taisent et qu'il n'ose pas aller
déposer plainte
d'ailleurs il faut former non les
policiers les gendarmes les magistrats
et peut-être justement mettre en place
des juridictions spécialisées c'est ce
que fait l'espagne apparemment ça ça
aussi ça a porté ses fruits
alors mieux former les professionnels
que ce soit les gendarmes les policiers
prennent les plaintes qui perdent qui
prennent les plaintes mais de manière
plus large que la société dans son
ensemble soit plus sensibilisés pour
encourager une femme a à parler
lorsqu'on a des soupçons dans nos
propres entourage c'est essentiel donc
que le sujet se démocratise et que l'on
n'ose enfin briser ce tabou c'est c'est
pour moi primordial
ensuite sur la question des juridictions
spécialisées moi en tant que juriste
oui je suis toujours très réservé sur
les juridictions spécialisées en
revanche qu'il y ait une procédure plus
rapide pour qu'il y ait une réponse
pénale plus prompte pour faire en sorte
que ces femmes soient protégés que l'on
puisse qu'elle puisse reconstruire et
être bien accompagné
ça oui mais de là à créer une procédure
une juridiction totalement spécialisés
non mais avoir un canal et des chambres
dans les tgi où les cours d'appel voilà
très très spécialisés pour permettre une
réponse rapide ça je crois que c'est une
bonne solution
elle essaie déjà pinal dernier sujet de
cette émission l'arrivée du budget de la
sécu au sénat un texte qui fait
quasiment l'unanimité contre lui dénoncé
par la gauche mercredi et par la droite
jeudi la majorité sénatoriale voit rouge
samia de sheer après les sénateurs
socialistes c'est au tour des
républicains de dénoncé le creusement
annoncée du déficit de la sécurité
sociale alors qu'il était presque à
l'équilibré en 2018
le budget sera déficitaire de 5
milliards d'euros l'an prochain
un déséquilibre dû à une perte de
recettes de 3,7 milliards d'euros dont
2,7 milliards s'explique par les mesures
accordées après la crise des gilet jaune
essentiellement des suppressions de
cotisation une perte non compensés par
l'état dénonce les républicains pour
bercy plonge les comptes de la sécu dans
le rouge et menace la survie d'un
système paritaire basées sur les
cotisations sociales
le danger de tout cela c'est que
progressivement
c'est un système financé par l'impôt
donc un système du type de anglo saxons
certains sceptiques air est ce système
anglo saxon s'il est mis en place
complètement un jour
vous serez remboursé en fonction de vos
moyens compenser la perte de recettes
liées à des mesures prises par l'état
est normalement une obligation légale
depuis 1994 les républicains vont tenter
de l'obtenir en amendant le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale la semaine prochaine il dénonce
aussi l'insuffisance des moyens budgétés
pour 2020 l'an prochain le secteur de la
santé devrait économiser 4 milliards
d'euros dont 800 millions d'euros pour
l'hôpital pour la droite sénatoriale le
rythme des économies n'est plus tenable
il est urgent de réformer le système on
aura des propositions sur la réforme de
la retraite on proposera 64 ans parce
qu'on dira aux français
faut pas se cacher si on recule pas
l'âge de de recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite ce sera moins de pouvoir
d'achat on sera obligé de baisser les
pensions et nous nous voulons garantir
le pouvoir d'achat des retraités
l'an prochain les retraites et
prestations familiales ne seront pas
revalorisés à hauteur de l'inflation
la branche retraite va donc perdre 600
millions d'euros et la branche famille
400 millions d'euros avec la politique
du gouvernement à ce que ce qui nous
guette
à terme c'est d'arriver un système anglo
saxon financé par l'impôt ou au fini par
être soignés en fonction de ses moyens
c'est la crainte du président de la
commission des affaires sociales alain
milon écoutez moi je constate que
finalement c'est plfss se suivent
d'année en année et ne règle pas les
véritables problématiques en termes
d'accès aux soins et ne rassure pas non
plus les français
la première année c'était l'augmentation
de la csg et puis cette année on est
finalement dans la poursuite de ceux qui
avaient été engagées avec effectivement
des craintes que les inégalités les
fractures à la fois sociales mais aussi
entre les territoires se poursuivre et
même s'accentue donc on peut craindre
effectivement d'aller vers de plus
graves inégalités et vous craignez vous
pensez que le gouvernement n'affiche pas
clairement ses intentions et vise à
terme comme le dit le sénateur
lr c'est pas rien que ce soit un
sénateur alors qu'ils existent qu'il
vise à terme une un système anglo saxon
en fait où chacun va la fin de
l'universalité
ces thèmes sont effectivement c'est un
vrai risque c'est moyen nous le
dénonçons régulièrement
et puis je constate que ce plfss passe
aussi à côté j'ai de la sécu pour 2010
étaient des vrais problèmes
regardez par exemple ce qui se passe
dans les urgences dans les hôpitaux
risquent de l'hôpital dans les hôpitaux
de proximité
on est en plein débat du plfss et la
ministre de la santé dit je présenterai
un plan pour l'hôpital la semaine
prochaine qui sert à quoi ce budget
pourrait justement je me dis à quoi sert
ce budget de la sécu quand on ne
présente pas les vraies mesures
attendues pour sortir l'hôpital et les
urgences de la crise profonde dans
laquelle il se trouve et à quoi sert
aussi le parlement regardez les débats à
l'assemblée
on était en plein débat on nous dit on
fera une présentation la semaine
prochaine autres préoccupations de la
majorité sénatoriale la perte de pouvoir
d'achat pour les retraités pour les
familles avec le quasi gel des pensions
de retraites et des prestations sociales
est ce que pour vous c'est justifié
évidemment non et nous avons ici à
l'assemblée essayer d'obtenir cette
revalorisation et notamment des plus
petites pensions moi je suis issu d'un
département agricole et vous connaissez
tous le droit à l'égard des retraités de
l'agriculture bien toutes ces petites
pensions ne sont jamais revalorisée et
et puis avec le problème de la csg qui
avait eu les années précédentes
enfin je vais continuer à traquer je
considère vraiment que quand on parle
des inégalités ce plfss continue
justement à creuser ces inégalités s'est
fracturé que nous dénonçons depuis le
premier un mot sur l'une des
modifications apportées par la droite
sénatoriale qui met l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite à 64 ans dans le
texte comme quasiment chaque année ça a
le mérite d'être plus clair que eh bien
ce que dit le gouvernement
c'est ça me paraît difficile d'être
moins clair que que se dit est que ce
que dit le gouvernement actuellement il
ya une vraie contradiction il ya une
concertation qui devait être finalement
la marque de l'acte 2 du quinquennat on
voit bien qu'il ya des contradictions
entre le haut commissaire
le premier ministre le président la
république finalement on voit bien que
ils ne sont pas très au clair sur ce
qu'ils veulent faire de la réforme des
retraites est la conséquence de tout ça
c'est quoi c'est que les français
s'inquiètent que dans nos territoires on
voit bien que les personnes qui sont sur
le point d'être à la retraite ou ceux
qui le seront dans quelques années se
demande si les réformes pour les
concernés ou pas se demande comment les
choses vont se passer et donc au lieu de
restaurer la confiance et de renouer ce
lien avec les français ont fini par
encore le disent dans le détendre et de
s'éloigner de plus en plus des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens
sylvia pinel on va terminer par une
image cette émission damien abad qui a
été élu nouveau président du groupe lr à
l'assemblée après neuf ans de présidence
de christian jacob qui est parti prendre
la tête d'un parti en crise est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est un bon profil pour
la droite à l'assemblée pour le parti à
l'heure où je n'ai pas pour habitude de
m'immiscer dans les relations politiques
des deux autres formations mois pour
avoir présidé mon parti je sais que
c'est toujours des choses très de ce
complexe et de l'homme d'amiens mais moi
je trouve que c'est une
une bonne une bonne image puisque vous
parliez de l'image et puis je lui
souhaite surtout bon courage dans sa
tâche qui me semble compliqué c'est
aussi un changement générationnel à la
tête du groupe l air qu est ce que vous
en pensez vous qu'ils avaient été on l'a
dit au début de cette émission benjamine
de cette assemblée
moi je suis toujours très heureuse
lorsque je vois qu'il ya un
renouvellement lorsque je vois que de
nouvelles têtes émergent en crevant
damien trop pour prendre des
responsabilités c'est toujours quelque
chose d'intéressant et de positif a
souligné
voilà après mon courage dans sa tâche
encore une fois qu'il me semble un peu
compliqué merci beaucoup sylvia pinel
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette émission
notre invité la semaine prochaine sera
le sénateur centriste président du
groupe centriste au sénat hervé
marseille
merci de votre fidélité ciao
[Musique]